let's go next to oh boy I have no idea
how to say this name I believe it's a
Scottish name it looks like it would be
is it I'm going to just take a wild
guess at how it's pronounced even though
there's so many is it pronounced Rory
you are very close is uh Rory Rory well
listen Rory from Scotland welcome to the
program
hi there
what's on your mind I was just uh I was
just thinking just because you know I
have sort of like an outside view of the
us obviously being from across the pond
I was just wondering what your opinion
was on the sort of like Global
right-wing populist movement whether you
think it was as strong as it was back in
2000 during the 2010s when you know
brexit happened and Trump got elected
and all that or do you think now it's in
more of a retreat and you see some of
these extreme policies come from the
Republicans and the conservatives over
here as their last kind of like flailing
of a sort of like ideology that's kind
of failing at the moment I don't have
anything empirical to tell you globally
about whether the right-wing populist
movement is in Retreat or not my feeling
okay so I'm just going by feeling and I
know facts don't care about feelings but
I have no facts so I'm going to give you
my feelings right my feeling is that
because of the losses that the Maga
right-wing populist movement has
suffered now multiple elections in a row
in the United States and the degree to
which Auntie woke doesn't seem to be
winning and they're suffering legal
defeats and moral defeats my feeling is
that it is at least starting a retreat
at this time
yeah
and I don't know what gets us in terms
of like the 2024 election necessarily
yeah for sure like I I kind of for in
the UK it's kind of the same because you
have the conservatives who have like
been trounced at local elections and
they're polling really badly nationally
but they're still like pushing the same
sort of like culture War policies that
have just kind of been imported from
America so like the whole trans rights
debates has flared up especially uh
where I'm from in Scotland
uh so I I think just looking over here I
think in some places like the US and the
UK is faltering quite a lot just because
of not necessarily the ideology in
itself but the incompetent people behind
it it's both right I mean you can you
can take bad ideas and popularize them
with competent demagogues you can take
uh good ideas and see them lose
miserably because the messengers aren't
good you could both can have yeah
exactly yeah
all right that's all I want to ask yeah
thank you very much I appreciate it
great to hear from you excellent always
uh welcoming our Scottish callers let's
go to Gene from Long Island Gene welcome
to the David packman show what is on
your mind today
hello yeah you're on the air
awesome
um my dad has raised me as a progressive
and the most thing uh the thing I've
cared most about while growing up is
Reproductive Rights okay and so we've
been blaming the GOP and Trump taking
credit for overturning Roe but looking
back I'm thinking the Democrats should
have made sure this right remained in
place they knew the GOP was planning and
plotting for all these years and my
other uh I wanted to get your thoughts
on that and also how how I can help in
this fight to get it to get those
Reproductive Rights back I've donated to
Planned Parenthood but uh you know if
there if you had any insight on Insight
on that as well so the first criticism
is a fair one which is couldn't
Democrats when they did control the
House and Senate and presidency have
codified Roe v Wade such that it would
no longer be up to the Supreme Court to
do away with it is that more or less the
critique in yes absolutely I think it's
completely Fair my question is if Obama
couldn't even get background checks done
with the House and Senate after the
Sandy Hook shooting could they really
have codified Roe v Wade I don't know
the answer I don't know the answer but I
think as a criticism it's completely
Fair
yeah so there's a practical question
it's something that actually upsets me
a lot because this is something I've
cared about for a long time so you know
looking into the future hopefully at
some point
we can get that back and I just don't
know how that would be now in terms of
your other question what is the best use
of your time money resources whatever in
order to essentially what you're saying
is keep abortion legal and maintain
access to it for people who want to
access it without being done away with
with Roe v Wade being done away with
right now this is a state issue so
in the states that have passed
restrictive laws You could argue it
makes sense to focus there so I don't
know exactly whether it should be focus
on getting candidates at the state level
in these states that have essentially
banned abortion
to get elected so maybe they can
overturn it or is it donating to Planned
Parenthood of Florida or Texas or
whatever I don't pretend to know exactly
I probably it's in all of the above
approach but I think that for as long as
it remains a state issue which it is
right now the focus for activists should
be on the states in which it is most in
peril
awesome thank you I really appreciate it
all right Gene from Long Island great to
hear from you uh very strong questions
today I must say one of our sponsors
today is Bon charge I have always
enjoyed dry saunas you get in there your
heart rate is up dilates the blood
vessels can soothe achy joints and
muscles it's relaxing it's just a great
way to remove a little stress Bond
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it and you'll get
15 off when you go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below